le froid trois cent mille français
privés d'électricité un gel va
s'accentuer sur la moitié nord du pays
l'armée égyptienne en crise après le
raid meurtrier de commandos égyptiens
chypre
invité du journal yvan charpentier
président de la cgt les cadres avant les
élections et puis à 20h30 le premier
grand débat de la campagne électorale
georges marchais à l'interprète sur
antenne 2 et europe
monsieur bonsoir la france coupée en
deux au premier jour officiel de la
campagne électorale cela n'a rien de
surprenant mais n'est pas cela que je
vais vous parler c'est de la france
météorologiques la france du printemps
c'est du sud ouest essentiellement qui
nage dans le nid mozart et puis la
france sibérienne essentiellement dans
l'est et en normandie là bas la
situation est carrément dramatique
daniel brême qui a mis cette heure en
train pour revenir le deauville le
rapport de normandie ce dicton quand il
fait soleil le jour de la chandeleur la
terre est recouverte de neige cette fois
il a fait beau le 2 février et en
normandie on est à 6 fois et ça n'a rien
d'une petite neige ce soir encore de
nombreux villages sont complètement
privés d'électricité en normandie comme
dans l'est où plusieurs préfectures ont
décidé de reporter la rentrée scolaire
philippe gassot
début du printemps au sud bérézina au
nord dans le grand nord pourrait-on dire
- 10° à nancy où il ne fait pas plus
chaud qu'à stockholm près de verdun on
ne passe plus seuls les autoroutes paris
metz strasbourg ont été dégagés dans ce
secteur le sel vient à manquer pour
faire fondre le verglas les enfants sont
en vacances forcées le ramassage
scolaire est interrompue et ce qui est
plus grave encore c'est que
l'accumulation de givre sur les câbles
électriques a provoqué des ruptures qui
prit plusieurs villages du tout de la
haute saône et de belfort d'électricité
et parfois de pain dans l'eure le
calvados et la seine maritime
la situation n'est pas meilleure des
centaines de poteaux en béton ont été
brisés par la surcharge l'armée a dû
intervenir mais en dépit de la mise en
place de moyens exceptionnels trois cent
mille français sont ce soir dans le noir
et il recommandait d'économiser l'eau
qui risquent de manquer en cas d'arrêt
des pompes électriques
la circulation sur les routes
principales restent tout à fait
hasardeuses et les routes secondaires
sont déconseillés sauf nécessité
impérieuse le moyen de transport le plus
sûr reste le train qui est parfois
obligé de prendre des chemins détournés
pour éviter les congères on arrive
parfois en retard mais on arrive une des
conséquences du mauvais temps les
oiseaux meurent de faim on demande à la
population de les nourrir car le froid
va encore durer pour faire le bilan
économique du froid il faut attendre
donc le point l'attitude chien et
surtout vous l'avez vu ses conséquences
dramatiques en normandie alors j'invite
savoir tout de suite avec monsieur météo
comment cela va se passer demain
effectivement pour demain la
météorologie n'est pas optimiste allons
bon en effet on a toujours des pluies à
prévoir et du verglas dans une zone
allant de la bretagne aux régions du
centre et au nord des alpes avec du
verglas plus au nord de forte gelée dès
la nuit prochaine de leur de -8 à -10
degrés et même des températures
négatives dans la journée mais toutefois
une zone de temps plus doux dans le sud
ouest avec quelques pluies passagères et
même des éclaircies près de la
méditerranée j'aurai une donc au nord de
la seine ce n'est pas bon du tout
comment ça se passait pour la semaine à
venir pour les autres jours pour les
autres jours c'est toujours du temps
froid dans le nord et le nord-est c'est
une barrière qui est difficile à
franchir par les perturbations qui vont
venir jeudi ou vendredi
sur le sud-ouest de la france donnant
toujours jeudi ou vendredi matin une
zone de neige allant de la normandie au
berry au nord des alpes alors vous savez
que vendredi soir précisément samedi
matin début des vacances scolaires
notamment pour les échos n'est pas rien
comment ça va se passer il faut
recommander à ceux qui vont prendre la
route surtout ceux en direction du sud
vers les alpes ou du sud-ouest vers les
pyrénées le recommander les régions du
centre et du morvan où là il ya du
risque de verglas et de neige ceci au
contact de l'air froid de venant
d'allemagne et de l'air doux venant
l'océan donc évitez si possible ces
régions du morvan et peut-être prendre
l'autoroute si l'autoroute marche bien
c'est ce qui est recommandé pour les
jours à venir joe merce aucune nouvelle
ce soir en provenance du tchad aucune
information donc sur le sort de
christian maes jeunes français pris en
otage par les éléments incontrôlés du
frolinat qu'il ya un mois et demi
normalement ultimatum fixé par les
rebelles devait expirer aujourd'hui à
midi mais à rien n'est venu de djamena
en fait il semble qu'en coulisse
tractations et négociations se
poursuivent notamment avec l'aide des
autorités nigérianes j'ai bien dit
nigériane et il reste un très sérieux
espoir de sauver christian maes est en
revanche très vinckier à paris sur le
sort des cinq disparus qui s'il était
mort s'ajouterait donc aux cinq victimes
et aux 40 blessés de la catastrophe du
16e arrondissement
un quartier qui reprend très doucement
vie plusieurs habitants ont été
autorisés cet après midi à regagner
leurs appartements
un quartier meurtri à l'angle de la rue
raynouard et de l'avenue lamballe on
était pour éviter tout éboulements une
opération qui durera plusieurs jours
sans doute dans l'explosion a été
terrible
il faudra ensuite ouvrir la chaussée
pour savoir si la rupture de la
canalisation est due à un glissement de
terrain ou à une rupture de sous 10
à 300 mètres de là sans précipitation
des habitants commencent à regagner
leurs appartements à l'exception des
trois immeubles sinistrés mais pour la
plupart ils devront continuer de camper
dans le provisoire
évidemment il ya peut-être de l'eau j'en
sais rien c'est un petit peu le camping
bassin problème parce que ma femme est
enceinte et un enfant de deux ans et je
vois pas très bien comment on va faire
et pour ce soir vous allez vous
installer dans votre appartement vous
allez avoir une solution de rechange la
wii alors
vous pouvez pas vous installez vous
savez quand qu'on va revenir
l'électricité le gaz l'eau savent pas
mais normalement la semaine je pense
hélas que comment vous faites alors là
on sera en valais bertand à une petite
propriété à la campagne on va coucher le
soir à caen points jusque maintenant
vous avez peur d'habiter un petit peu ce
quartier - mais pas avec bertand du tout
voilà l'étranger le gros dossier et
reste toujours la sphère chypriote ce en
direct dans ce journal hier soir avec
des cordes des cuivres dans la confusion
le dénouement étonnant la prise d'otage
arabe par un commando palestinien
cela s'est passé sur l'aéroport de
nicosie là où tout avait commencé et les
observateurs ont du mal encore ce soir à
comprendre un avion égyptien qui disait
transporter des péni potentiel pour les
pourparlers avec les palestiniens
atterri à larnaca tout près de
l'appareil détourné et la surprise ce ne
sont pas des ministres qui descendent
mais une jeep et des commandos égyptiens
qui tire un petit peu partout y compris
sur la tour de contrôle où se trouvait
le président chypriote interloqué le
chef de l'état donne l'ordre à ses
troupes d'arrêter les égyptiens bilan 15
morts la reddition des terroristes et la
libération des passagers
c'était donc hier en fin d'après midi
17h30 le dc-8 avec ses deux palestiniens
et ses 11 otages revient à son point de
départ
larnaca le président de chypre et dans
la tour de contrôle trois heures de
négociations qui sont sur le point
d'aboutir
vers 21h les deux palestiniens sont
semble-t-il prêt à se rendre mais sur
une autre piste un c-130 atterri avec ou
non on ne sait pas très bien le feu vert
des autorités
150 commandos égyptiens descendent tire
un peu partout y compris vers la tour de
contrôle surpris dans la nuit noire la
plus complète les gardes chypriote
riposte font intervenir leurs blindés
pour protéger le dc-8 des otages en
quelques minutes 15 commandos égyptiens
sont tués
les autres faits prisonniers et dans la
panique générale
les deux palestiniens se rendent inde m
en libérant leur otage
la confusion était totale hier soir sur
l'aéroport de larnaca bruce avait la
pièce égyptienne élite d'ailleurs pas
aujourd'hui à titrer que ce sont
finalement les commandos égyptiens qui
ont réussi et oui à libérer les otages
et la mission du ministre égyptien
boutros rallier à chypre pour tenter de
recoller les morceaux est actuellement
en cours dans ces conditions il est très
difficile vous en doutez de réunir des
informations valables pour expliquer
comment on a pu aboutir un deuxième
temps le servent à traiter les commandes
aux ivryens avait pour mission de
libérer l'otage bien sûr mairie de
capturer les terroristes pour les
ramener au caire sinon de les abattre
sur place lula et y priaient voulait
faire preuve d'une grande fermeté et
sont à cet égard que l'indispensable
coordination avec les autorités
chypriotes elle même très soucieuses de
leur souveraineté et pas des paiements
réalisés des commandos égyptiens d'enppi
leurs instructions des fois sur
l'aéroport de larnaca que son oncle
effet emporté par leur zèle par leur
désir de vagues
comment l'armée syrienne très sensible à
l'endroit de son président qui a subi
hier soir un sérieux il faut bien le
dire a donc réagir une fois les
responsabilités établies c'est une grave
question le moins qu'on puisse dire à
cet égard c'est que si ce désastre et du
coke c'est probable un manque de
coordination
sur le plan strictement est livré à
cette fois entre l'état major et le
pouvoir politique qui risque de
provoquer des fissures profondes en
situation délicate actuelle au fond de
longues et dirigé à colmater en tout cas
entre le régime et ont armé émeutes
sanglantes en iran il y aurait près
d'une centaine de morts et beaucoup plus
de blessés encore au cours de
manifestations antigouvernementales qui
ont eu lieu à tabriz deuxième ville de
lempiras été littéralement saccagé par
des milliers de manifestants
dans les audits brejnev détendu et
souriant qui a accueilli le président
assad une ya quelques heures à moscou
une visite officielle de trois jours
pour le chef de l'état syrien au centre
de leurs entretiens le dernier sommet
d'alger du front de la fermeté et la
situation dans la corne de l'afrique
un mot sur le franc qui était encore un
peu pâlot aujourd'hui mais qui a mieux
résisté que le dollar en chute libre le
franc suisse en revanche ça pour la
première fois son histoire dépassé la
barre des deux francs 60 et j'en arrive
à la politique la politique ce soir
c'est essentiellement ce qui va se
passer dans quelques minutes sur antenne
2 et sur europe 1 à 20h30 en effet le
premier de nos grands débats commun
entre georges marchais et alain
peyrefitte sur place philippe harrouard
eh bien oui patrick c'est le premier
grand choc dans quelques instants la
campagne officielle avec ce débat entre
monsieur alain peyrefitte ministre de la
justice garde des sceaux et monsieur
georges marchais secrétaire général du
parti communiste français ce n'est pas
la première fois que les deux hommes se
rencontrent face à face à la télévision
la dernière fois rappelez vous il y
avait 6 ans exactement c'était armes
égales un premier face à face télévisé
et puis deux puis nous avons entendu à
la radio le studio 101 commencent à se
peupler un peu à la manière d'une
compétition sportive chacun est venu
avec ses supporteurs il sera évidemment
très intéressant de savoir à trois
semaines des élections ce conte à se
dire messieurs marchait et peyrefitte le
débat a donc lieu en public ici mais il
sera suivi surtout par des millions
d'auditeurs et de téléspectateurs
puisque ce débat est transmis
conjointement sur europe 1 et antenne 2
européen n 2 qui se sont unis pour créer
cet événement europe 1 et antenne 2 qui
s'uniront également pour vous présenter
les résultats des élections les nuits du
12 et 19 mars le débat est arbitrée par
etienne mougeotte et jean pierre
elkabbach
les directeurs de l'information d'europe
1 et d'antenne 2 il commence à 20h30
précises donc à tout à l'heure
les gaullistes de l'opposition engage la
bataille en ordre dispersé jean
charbonnel eloi monde présente une
quarantaine de candidats union des
gaullistes de progrès de dominique
gallet représente une centaine trois
élections partielles dont l'avenir dira
s'il devait être ou non prémonitoire à
bonifacio en corse pour des municipales
c'est la majorité qui l'emportent sur
l'opposition qui avait gagné l'année
passée dans le val de marne la majorité
est là encore l'emportent dans une
cantonale à chennevières reprend un
siège à un communiste et elle ne souffre
que de cette voie dans un autre canton
du département à vincennes du coup les
communistes sont furieux charles
fiterman accuse tout simplement le ps
d'avoir délibérément fait battre le
candidat du pc une accusation qui
rachetaient énergiquement par gaston
defferre pas quand même moins
horizontale oui à partir de ces
résultats et à partir au site la
vivacité de la réaction des communistes
que l'on pouvait se poser bien des
questions première question le parti
socialiste at il voulu donner un
avertissement au parti communiste je
signale d'ailleurs que le mot
avertissement avait été prononcée en
sens inverse par le parti communiste il
ya un peu plus d'un an lors d'une
élection partielle à châtellerault
vienne et puis autre question
l'électorat socialiste s'est il
spontanément sans consigne détourner du
candidat communiste y aura-t-il une
sorte de phénomène de rejet consécutif à
la longue polémique en fait le parti
socialiste a fait ses comptes et il fait
observer que 85% de son électorat s'est
reportée sur le candidat communiste et
que les défections sont très localisés
dans la commune de l'oiseau il y aurait
des raisons particulières à cet effet à
cette défection divergences donc sur les
chiffres mais il ya surtout cette
divergence politique et dont vous parlez
le parti communiste accuse clairement le
parti socialiste d'avoir fait voter
pause pour la droite et le parti
socialiste de son côté lui se pose la
question le parti communiste veut-il
chercher dans cette affaire là un
prétexte pour justifier son refus de se
prononcer sur le fameux problème de
désistement secondes du ver est avec
nous le copain parce que du côté de la
majorité ce n'est pas vraiment le même
climat mais on note là aussi des bavures
avec des candidatures in extremis hier
soir un peu avant minuit les
candidatures visant à gêner à
l'intérieur de la majorité quelques
grands leaders gaulliste ou giscardien
c'était peut-être là un moyen de
pression puisque dès ce matin jean
pierre soisson annoncé qu'il était prêt
à retirer le cas échéant ces candidats
de dernière heure jean pierre soisson
qui venait de rencontrer le premier
ministre pour lui proposer une partie du
temps d'antenne du parti républicain à
la télévision proposition acceptée par
raymond barre et à la sortie de l'hôtel
matignon jean-pierre soisson devait
déclarer le premier ministre ne peut pas
être le chef d'une des tendances de la
majorité et voilà bien où le bât blesse
qui est le chef de l'idf alors qu'il
vient effectivement c'est la question
patrick l'on se pose depuis quelques
jours vous connaissez la réponse de
jacques chirac il l'avait fait à notre
antenne et le fcjs mais les partenaires
de jjss ne l'entendent pas de cette
façon et monsieur soissons dans sa
conversation avec monsieur bart l'a dit
d'ailleurs au premier ministre qui
paraît-il a acquiescé en souriant le
chef de l'état est ça ne peut pas tout
non plus monsieur répond marc lumens il
ne peut pas être le chef de la majorité
parce que le rpr lui a contesté ce rôle
il ne peut pas non plus être le chef
d'une tendance de la majorité contre une
autre le premier ministre et d'ailleurs
a été surpris du ton que l'udf se soit
référée aussi explicitement au président
de la république en particulier par ses
affiches le président lui-même s'est
situé au dessus des tendances et sa
majorité il peut être l'inspirateur de
l'udf mais s'il ne peut pas être lié à l
alors pour l'instant il n'y a pas encore
de réponse la question que vous posez
comme vous le disiez le climat n'est pas
le même dans la majorité dans
l'opposition mais voyez chacun ses
problèmes et puis du genre politique que
ce beau plateau réuni aujourd'hui par
les gir groupe initiatives et
responsabilités des groupe fondé par
michel de bâtisses yvan charpentier léon
gingembre et d'autres représentants de
cette fraction de quatre artisans et
professions libérales pour leur première
convention nationale l'hégire avait
voulu interroger raymond barre et les
représentants de quatre partis
politiques
avec 9500 adhérents l'hégire fait
aujourd'hui leur premier anniversaire
en effet le 1er mars 1977 au cours d'une
conférence de presse michel débâtisse
annoncé la création des groupes
initiative responsabilités voulant se
situer entre le patronat français et les
centrales syndicales ouvrières les
girons invités pour leur première
convention nationale à se succéder
respectivement la tribune jean pierre
soisson jean colpin jacques chirac henri
caillavet et raymond barre pour jan
cools pas la seule solution de survie
pour les gir c'est l'application du
programme commun actualisées
pour jacques chirac il a prononcé quant
à lui un vibrant hommage un vibrant
plaidoyer en faveur des pme dans un
environnement libéral et à dénoncer je
cite le tatillonne isme excessif de
l'administration enfin raymond bas a
tenu à mettre en garde les responsables
des classes moyennes sur le risque leur
ferait courir l'application du programme
commun votre avenir at il dit est menacé
parce qu'ils voudraient appliquer sur la
france un modèle économique
voilà avec nous il un charpentier alors
ccj à ces groupes iniciativas
possibilités dont vous êtes l'un des
fondateurs qu'est ce que c'est que je
demande c'est pas un petit peu une sorte
de groupes de pression de lobbys en ce
moment à quinze jours des élections
traces n'ont pas du tout les gir là au
cours de cette réunion ont interrogé les
partis politiques et tous les partis
politiques avaient été invités répondent
ainsi ceux qui sont
parmi ces classes moyennes pourront être
éclairée par les leaders des partis
politiques mais ce qu'ils ont dit que
les gir était une machine de guerre
politique pour constater que les gir ne
se prononce pas sur des choix politiques
dia nancy maintenant responsable de la
stylistique je m'adresse j'ai découvert
en faisant des recherches qu'ils y
allaient finalement francs deux fois
plus de cadres que l'agriculteur ça peu
de gens le savent ça prouve que les
cadres sont quand même un moyen de
pression important effectivement à
quelques semaines d'élections
législatives alors est-ce que vous même
vous allez appeler à voter pour tel ou
tel parti c'est vrai vous avez raison en
ce moment de période préélectorale il ya
beaucoup de sourires qui nous sont faits
venant de tous les côtés mais nous avons
l'habitude d'avoir vu des sourires suivi
ensuite par des grimaces une fois que la
fièvre électorale est tombé et que les
élus sont installés alors de notre côté
nous sommes une organisation totalement
indépendant des partis politiques je
crois pas qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'organisations qui puisse le dire et
par conséquent nous ne donnerons pas de
consignes de vote alors georges séguy ya
quand même appelé à voter pour le pc on
sait qu andré bergeron edmond maire ont
une carte du ps on sait rien vous vous
allez appeler à voter pour qui vous
allez voter pour qui vous pages à lire
et est d'abord à tous nos cadres que
premièrement ils aillent voter c'est
leur devoir de citoyen deuxièmement
qu'ils votent selon leur conscience nous
n'avons pas à leur dicter le vote le
bulletin de vote qui vont mettre dans
l'urne hissant à ces grands garçons ils
sont des citoyens responsables ils n'ont
pas besoin de nous est ce que je
voudrais dire et je les dis devant 12
cents militants ce après midi c'est que
nous sommes décidé quant à nous en étant
nous mêmes un état une organisation
syndicale à des formes quoi qu'il arrive
les intérêts légitimes et moraux de nos
adhérents aller car nous pensons que un
peu trop dans les périodes électorales
beaucoup parce qu'après tout les cadres
pourraient se payer pour assurer le
progrès social les sondages disent que
ils sont à peu près à 50 50 vous savez
nous ne sommes pas autre chose que des
gens très moyen de la société moderne
alors que l'on ne s'étonne pas si l'on
retrouve les cadres à peu près au même
niveau que le français moyen se veut
être la preuve que les cadres eux mêmes
chacun d'entre nous et peut-être un peu
partagés sur ce tueur a fait enfin venez
à moi je crois que nous ne nous sommes
favorables un certain nombre de grands
principes que nous avons rappelé tout
autour de la campagne d'automne ce que
je puis dire c'est que nous aurons peu
et je les dix après midi devant nos
militants et bien sans connaître
aujourd'hui qui sera le premier ministre
après les élections législatives
nous avons pris rendez vous avec celui
ci car nous aurons lui faire connaître
un certain nombre de préoccupations et
notamment la première qui est la nôtre
notre préoccupation de l'emploi en lui
demandant de réunir avec le patronat et
les autres organisations syndicales un
sommet sur l'emploi car c'est là le
problème numéro un de la france
d'aujourd'hui problème difficile à
résoudre ô combien il en charpente il ya
quinze jours porte maillot palais des
congrès y avait deux réunions l'une avec
raymond barre l'autre avec françois
mitterrand me dit que vous allez passer
plusieurs heures à celle de raymond
barre et un quart d'heure seulement à
celle de françois mitterrand c'est un
début de choix non ce n'est pas début de
choix j'étais l'invité de monsieur
gattaz qui a fait un face à face avec
moi ou bien entendu nous avons dit nous
nous sommes dit entre cadres et chefs
d'entreprise les 4 vérités et de notre
côté il y avait une réunion nous avions
été invités par le parti socialiste j'ai
été car je crois que nous il y avait
également deux collègues du bureau qui
on peut y participer toute la journée
nous sommes ouverts nous a tous les
contacts nous avons rencontré d'ailleurs
tous les partis pris à l'acception du pc
je le regrette personnellement ça
viendra peut-être réélection mais nous
sommes ouverts et nous ne voulons pas
nous engager dans un choix politique
déterminé ce qui ne veut pas dire que
nous sommes indifférents l'égard d'un
certain nombre de propositions des
partis politiques et il y en a certains
qui nous inquiète par exemple la
disparition de nos régimes
complémentaires de retraite par exemple
qui est écrit dans le programme commun à
s'agissant de la hiérarchie des
rémunérations
vous savez on a critiqué en à critiquer
monsieur bart quand il était premier
ministre et qu'il a fait un plan de
relance où on nous demande notamment un
impôt sécheresse croyez-vous qu'on veut
attendre que le programme commun son
application pour critiquer un certain
nombre d'éléments qui y sont contenues
je crois que c'est notre rôle
d'organisation syndicale de dire ce que
nous pensons comme nous le pensons et
comme justement nous sommes totalement
indépendants des partis politiques je
crois que notre liberté d'expression
prend sans doute une beaucoup plus
grande valeur je remercie je me sens pas
tout à fait tout pour la politique ce
soir vous savez que depuis le début de
l'année nous avons essayé de porter un
autre regard sur la bataille électorale
en nous déplaçant dans les
circonscriptions pour essayer de
comprendre les vrais problèmes cette
semaine nous avons essayé d'aller encore
plus loin en plein temps nos caméras
dans une ville moyenne de ce que l'on
appelle la douce france c'est à dire les
pays de loire cette ville c'est chinon
louis doucet et jacques delarue vont
essayer de vous faire vivre tout au long
de la semaine comment là bas on vit la
politique comment on la conçoit
ce matin l'après de la chine où le
premier ministre raymond barre il ne
dure et un crs de l'autre côté de la rue
quelques manifestants brandissaient une
pancarte qu'il devait bien avoir leur
idée sur ce que l'on appelle la
politique la politique pour moi les
teams le mot politique veut dire gérer
la cité ça veut pas dire politicards ça
veut pas dire comment nous on nous prend
pour des gens qui veulent tout casser
tout ça vous êtes des politiciens des
mails tous des trucs comme ça le mot
politique veut dire gérer la cité alors
nous on fait de la politique on gère la
cité
la même question je les pose est à
quelques invités dans l'assistance la
politique qu'est ce que c'est faut pas
me parler de politique moi je connais
rien mais pourquoi êtes-vous ici
aujourd'hui pour marc media bar c'est à
dire qu'enfin tout le monde veut le
bonheur des gens du monde où seuls les
conceptions philosophiques chaînes
changent et la limite alors que les les
moyens pour le faire sur les mêmes pour
pratiquement tout le monde
savez
la politique c'est au fond la
l'administration et ainsi nous concerne
l'administration de la cité s'étoffant
la bonne gestion autant que faire se
peut de cécité et tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord avec vous oh mais c'est
saignant ce serait trop beau mais mairie
à lille que tout le monde soit d'accord
avec une personne je ne pense pas que ce
soit vidé déjà d'ailleurs dans
l'histoire ne serait ce que l'histoire
politique mais lorsque l'on essaie de
faire en sorte que ce qu'ils soient
faits repose sur une étude qui a été bon
pour elle a très bien fait ou ne fait le
mieux possible mais évidemment ça qu'on
tentera une certaine partie des gens ça
ne pourra jamais contenter tout le monde
politique du break police paie pour
quelle vitesse qui veut lire la cité
chine ont donc une cité de 8300 habitant
une petite ville ni à droite ni à gauche
qui sont centristes avec un penchant
légèrement conservateur
sinon c'est un peu la france dans le
sens où la france c'est la somme de ceux
qui à fait seule l'histoire et cela pas
forcément à paris comme on imagine trop
souvent exemple l'an bêta est originaire
de cahors pour bon d'un vallon jaurès de
castres et c'est ici à chinon on a vu
tout le monde le sait la rencontre de
jeanne d'arc avec charles vii qui marqua
le destin du pays
rabelais est ici et il y a quelques
années la première centrale nucléaire de
l'edf alors vous voyez entre le château
là haut les bords de la vienne si on
continue à jouer sa partie dans
l'histoire de france c'est à dire dans
la politique française
de quelle manière cela est bien ici
comme ailleurs les citoyens ont une
opinion qu'ils expriment pas l'occasion
par un bulletin de vote mais plus
souvent encore par la parole
ainsi quand on demande aux anciens de
résumer ce qu'une vie d'observation leur
a pris de la politique voilà ce que
certains sont portés à répondre
trop de politique en france c'est un mal
et on nous promet au moment des
élections énormément de choses
malheureusement beaucoup trop de choses
auxquelles se réalise non je vais
abandonner un politique et les veaux tic
pourquoi parce que ça me dégoûte
mais pourquoi sauter vous
nettoyer ce à l'heure actuelle pour lui
impose radio la télé s'est jamais que
des clans politiques qui sont les uns
sur des douilles et ça n'en finit plus
une écurie vous avez l'impression que
pour passe au dessus de vos têtes sans
tenir compte de votre vie ou quoi bon
gars creux mais c'est pas assez d'action
tout le monde n'a pas l'air d'accord
pourquoi
je trouve que c'est exact il ya tout de
même eu beaucoup d'amélioration depuis
quelques semaines il ya certaines choses
qui sont
améliorées
voilà demain louis doucet nous dira
comment là bas on vit l'affrontement
majorité opposition je vais vous dire
aussi qu'en france la consommation de
vin a baissé de 27% ce qui a révélé la
revue mensuelle 30 jours d'europe 27 %
en 20 ans dans l'europe des petits
verres c'est quand même jour la france
qui détient le record de consommation
avec plus de 100 litres par habitant
elle y précède l'italie mais en
consommation d'alcool toutes catégories
cette fois ci c'est la belgique qui nous
souffle la première place et oui devant
la grande bretagne devant nous et puis
la grande bretagne derrière voilà c'est
sur ces réflexions que se termine ce
journal je rappelle quand n 2 comme dans
toutes les sociétés issues de lexware
tfc bien certain nombre de personnels
sont en grève aujourd'hui par solidarité
avec ceux de l'ina mais qu
exceptionnellement vous pourrez suivre
le débat prévu georges marchais alain
peyrefitte tout de suite après la
publicité merci nous avoir prêté ce soir
encore attention à demain